[Music]
okay everybody this is my spoiler review
of severance episode 4 the uur
the title of mark's brother-in-law's
book which you'll see even appear in
this episode which we'll get to but
what's interesting is the first episode
not directed by ben stiller it's
directed by ifa mcardle and written by
carrie drake so this show to me just
keeps getting better and better and this
is a particular episode that is so much
better on rewatch you catch a lot more
things which i'm going to break down
what i saw and stuff that's just getting
my mind spinning right now but really
really powerful stuff as well in this
episode we've talked about in previous
reviews the commentary on that corporate
work lifestyle and making you question
what we're even doing right and it's so
timely
in this time we're in it's the great
resignation right now so i think this is
going to speak to a lot of people i know
it did for me but let's break it down
with what's going on with the shocking
ending and a lot of stuff we learned
about helly here so helly at the
beginning is right where we left off
she's still in this break room so
miltrex are afraid you don't mean it and
then he wants to continue this in the
morning with heli right but they
highlight the cut she has an arm which
is super important because when we see
she comes back down the elevator that
she's in a new outfit again it's the
next morning but her arm is completely
fine so we know throughout this episode
i knew from the past that her audi is
hell-bent on her
being in this office and working here
and it makes so much sense how they
wrote this character of holly because
she is stubborn in both versions of
herself right she is hard-headed what
she does is she is set on and she's
going to do it no one's going to get in
her way and that's for good and for bad
here but clearly her audi didn't even
care about her arm bleeding because they
didn't have to make an excuse for her
like milk check wasn't like wait take
this note with you nothing they know
that she's gonna be fine with it and it
makes you wonder what is the deal with
this audi right like is she even working
in the building at this point another
floor what is going on she came back we
see later in episode the same day with
the same outfit when she was sent out
again so it's a lot to get your mind
thinking about what's going on with heli
but we see in this morning session here
that when she's back in the break room
we hear this angry mumbling voice of a
man and she notices it and it's
interesting too because when she
reflects on the break room with dylan
later on dylan says crying baby to this
and that that's what he had heard so
that's really fascinating and what does
this voice mean for each person in this
break room but we saw it took her
1072 times to be let go and convince
this lie detector she was telling the
truth about being sorry but you know
zack cherry just delivers great lines as
dylan here being the comic relief but
i'm someone where i actually am taking
what the character of dylan is saying
seriously i think he's saying truth when
he just casually says things about omd
for example and that you know they're
just bombing people and their bowels i
don't think that's you know something to
take light it's put as humor but i think
there's probably truth to it and i just
love maybe the funniest line episode
here is when he says to helly about
learning how to trick the lie detector
machine he has to feel sorry about
something and that of course the thing
he feels sorry about is imagining his
audi with milfs but pitying the husbands
i thought that was so funny and just
great dark comedy so what's interesting
is helly notices
that mark here is looking at this map of
pd's and then finds it later on and it's
interesting when they're all talking
about the map and heli rightfully calls
out mark for his hypocrisy this guy is
the one who's always telling her to obey
the rules but he's always sneakily doing
stuff on the side but this seems really
important to show us mark's character in
a nutshell because he quickly downplays
it all and says that eagan has a rule
about not mapping and heli calls him out
like you're more loyal to this place
than your actual best friend but this is
where mark starts to sound really crazy
here he's like the work is mysterious
uncertain the way keir wanted we deal
with it as a family so mark is just an
interesting character and we're seeing
how much he's been brainwashed working
here and how much his mind has changed
we get little glimpses of the mark
before working here come through and the
mark we know as an audi and it sums them
up though because yeah he does care
about this with the map and he does care
about the book we see he's shown by
irving later on but it also is when he's
really threatened his work life and his
image he'll still choose that over
whatever pd's showing him whatever he
really cares about deep down and that is
where he's currently at and it needs to
change for him to really catch on about
what he's trying to learn from his audi
and i love though he puts this in the
paper shredder that extreme and it's
haunting and it's sad to helly too you
know it's like any chance of hope here
just all this stuff contributing to her
choice of suicide by the end of the
episode so through irving we get to see
owen d here right and he gets to go on a
tour he's excited about it and we see
felicia goes on a supply run right
that's why she's not there after seeing
him for like a second and you know just
learn through this episode that ond is
basically a front optics and design all
this art they're putting out that's the
job on the outside but irving will see
this huge room and we learn that it's
not just burt and felicia that work in
this department it's a bunch of people
and you have to then okay see that there
is truth to what dylan's been saying
about this department they're up to
something else they do something messed
up and it was cool that we got to see a
glimpse of that through irving's eyes
and we also get this big moment where
irving and bert are looking at this
painting of a child who is sick that
they hold hands with each other and
bert's the one who really makes the
aggressive motion so that kind of caught
me off guard and that there's a deeper
bond there besides you know him admiring
someone who's above him in work that
there is actually some romantic
connection going on between these two
men but when irving leaves o and d in
the beginning this episode you know he
decides not to use the map to get back
and that will have him cross this
conference room and see the book that
milchik left there which was silly that
he left it there and not keeping that
more you know tight knit but i guess he
didn't expect irving to walk over there
because he was supposed to be there and
this is where he finds rickon's book the
uur and he tells mark because mark is
his supervisor but this is huge because
again this is mark's brother-in-law and
he is not supposed to even get an idea
of him existing and all of this stuff in
the book is just anti-work anyway so he
shouldn't be reading in so many ways but
what i like is irving quotes the
handbook every time he does this it's
really like someone quoting the bible
and it's so interesting because then
when he's talking about here egan with
bert later on the way burt talks about
first editions right of cures rules it's
like someone talking about the old
testament verse the new testament which
i thought was fascinating and how holy
they have this handbook but you see
there's not supposed to be any books
besides the handbook but that the note
to mark from rick in the book was
intrepid cartographer of the mind so to
translate that he's a fearless mapper of
the mind right so that's interesting too
that rick and even thinks of him that
way and makes us just question more
about mark's audi and what his true
intentions are about life and about just
mental health in general and there's
little lines that are important here too
that we'll probably see in a flashback
where irving says you know maybe this is
a loyalty test and they bring up the
spicy candy so you gotta wonder what the
hell that test was of loyalty but again
we'll see mark with this behavior where
he doesn't do what he's actually saying
or he's gonna return the book he keeps
it and we'll see dylan later on sees
that he kept it and he's like i should
have known because that's what mark is
known to do he's always so close to just
catching on to everything and then
eventually his obedient side takes over
so we see heli goes and threatens peggy
to cut her fingers off if they don't let
her film a video to her audi about why
she should resign now i thought it was
so fascinating when they're filming heli
here that the camera already had six
minutes of footage on it so you're
wondering if they filmed something that
helie needed to see outside first to
explain why she was even getting this
video so something's up there and they
only showed in the footage she has a
slicer in her hand so the heli the audi
knows that she was gonna hurt herself
and all we saw was of that footage her
saying hey so we don't know if they edit
it tamper with it for the audi heli to
see but even so i don't even think the
audi heli even cares because again she's
clearly in on this and i love the line
heli has to mark before she goes in the
elevator with the tape well boss guess
this is the part where i should tell you
go to hell except you're already here so
obviously just great writing here and
every line here even if it doesn't move
the plot along it has some meaning to it
and just really shapes how we're
supposed to think about situations we're
seeing in the show so what is crazy
though is you're expecting when she was
to come back down that elevator to be a
different day maybe that she'd look
different but this was so fast that her
audi rejected this tape that she's in
the same outfit same day she's giving
back a tape that her audi filmed so it
makes me think she's in that building
her audi at certain points or maybe she
had a more complicated surgery too that
there's multiple versions of heli going
on here and what's the best scene in
this episode is when you know workie
hell is watching audi heli on tape
talking to herself she's like eventually
we all have to accept reality i'm a
person you are not i make the decisions
you do not and if you ever do anything
to my fingers no i'll keep you alive
long enough to make you horribly regret
that so what's so ironic about this is
that the helly audi underestimated her
working heli and that she would go even
to the line of suicide so that's what's
just crazy about this character of helly
and so fascinating and seeing her verse
herself in a way and us getting excited
to learn more about the audi helly and
how she even got to this point what does
she really like but we're getting so
many hints by her behavior inside but
this audi heli is more extreme the other
way in belief but either way she is an
extremist in both versions now going to
the audi mark here we saw the
cliffhanger last week he has pd's phone
and keeps ringing it's a block number
and throughout this episode he's still
ignoring the vibrating he's hearing from
petey's phone and we're wondering who is
this block number calling and why mark
is so hesitant and that he's still in
denial of parts about all what's going
on because he still wants to work at
lumen and still has to get over his
grief with losing his wife and using
lumen as a way to ignore it which was
pretty much called out by petey's
daughter in this episode to him that
this place of loom is just a place to
shut off from facing basically your
messed up life and that's why i was so
brilliant that after that line he will
go and visit the crash site of his wife
and a beautiful moment by adam scott you
know having that grief come in and
actually facing in a more healthy way
and not just ignoring it facing the
grief head on which his character is
going to have to do to kind of catch on
to everything at his job to get through
this grief first and adam scott's just
looking for that emmy here it's amazing
watching him he's always been amazing to
watch but showing the range he has and
it was beautifully shot i love how they
use so much darkness on his face during
the stark moment but let his performance
still shine through with the crying it
was such a realistic grief stricken cry
too so amazing acting by adam scott with
that little piano as well just helping
it so much too but what makes this story
with mark so interesting at the funeral
pd is bringing peggy into the fold and
we see it at lumen that the scary guard
aluminum forms peggy that petey's body
is going to be cremated and she's like
we have to get that chip now she wants
that chip because it's her proof to the
board that pd's chip was messed with
that reintegration is a thing because
like the guard says they still don't
acknowledge at the board they don't
believe it's possible and we see peggy
has to remind herself of a mantra of
lumen values here and looking at a
former lumen ceo and it's like
motivating to do what really she think
is just for lumen and what's surreal
about what's going on is peggy's seeing
mark at the funeral it's subconsciously
making mark even question like why is my
neighbor here because he doesn't know
it's peggy and what i loved about seeing
mark at this funeral of pd's is that
fascinating thing of you know you didn't
even know him the ex-wife nina says
right because she knows what lumen's
about and he's like well i think it's
someone i knew so i should be here but
we also know mark knows more than that
and he's not leading that on to people
he has to still keep secret that he
wasn't talking to pd outside of work and
that's what's great about this concept
being a unique fresh take in this show
that we can enjoy and watch these
interesting situations race to tiptoe
around everybody and having this cool
effect of like having two versions of
yourself and people knowing that now i
love to when they're in the church in
the funeral service and they're playing
the enter sandman video and the
character of june is playing it on the
guitar it's a perfect song to be playing
while peggy is the sandman in the show
right and that she's taking mark's chip
out of his dead corpse which is just
crazy and was great suspense because in
this moment mark is now thinking about
pd outside of work during this and the
moments he saw him but he thinks about
peggy watching him here which is huge so
he's really starting to catch on to
things now and that's why he goes to
pd's casket to check on it and he just
misses peggy here so peggy got really
lucky and because of mark's suspicious
behavior here this is why peggy wants
him now to have a serious wellness check
and peggy also gives milchick petey's
chip for diagnostics because again she
wants this studied and proven to the
board that this was messed with and that
reintegration is a thing and you see
even milchik is like shocked and worried
that it's mark she's asking to have this
wellness session it's like showing you
that milk check knows too that it's a
screwed up thing and that he does
actually care about mark a bit and she's
like he just needs it trust me she wants
all those paranoid thoughts of mark
cleansed and what we'll get more
theories going on reddit is this line
bert says to irving when they reunite
later on talking about kieran he's like
he doesn't just speak to us through the
handbook paintings he finds other ways
that could be through people again
through the brainwashing so much stuff
going on it's so fascinating too and by
the way i really love how the director
here filmed this she did a lot of cool
shots just in the hallways the way she
would move the camera and make this
really feel like this building is a
giant maze and different and we're
watching these lab rats walk through it
and i also love mark in this moment in
the bathroom reading this book of
rickens and his passage about not
needing a job how he was happy this
summer he didn't have one and he says
that gray line your job needs you
not the other way around so it's so
timely and it's a big theme of this show
and i like they're doing this it's going
to speak to a lot of people right now
again because we're in the great
resignation but it's also speaking to
this character mark here and all this
stuff getting through to him to get him
out of this so i really love the last
sequence here and how it's all edited
together really well bringing up so much
suspense and everybody's stories kind of
hitting ahead at once and you know the
second i saw helly with the extension
cord i knew what was going down here
what her plan was and you know we see
dylan finds mark has the book in his
desk and it sets up dylan to be saying
the poem about destiny that rick and
wrote over everything here and we see
mark starting his wellness session we
see that candle that i had asked in
question like why did peggy take that
from the basement of marx now i know
she's just using it in the wellness room
and we see this is when irving at the
same time sneaks back into omd and he
gets this big information seeing this
big room and that they're doing
something else behind the scenes and my
heart was pounding through all this
knowing this inevitable course that heli
was gonna take here and that it's just a
haunting ending with her hanging herself
just shook you and you know i really
enjoy the character of helly so i'm not
sure if she's actually going to be dead
here because they just showed it at that
moment but we know that dylan knows
she's in the building he might catch on
just in time or the crazy thing is she
hanged herself in the elevator so it
makes you wonder that if that
accidentally goes up the elevator that
she's gonna tap into audi heli and be
like what the hell why am i hanging you
know and maybe she'll scream whatever i
don't know or she'll be caught on camera
but you know or she's just dead and
we'll just see heli through the audi
versions in the past getting more
information about her how she got here
and it's going to shake up the whole
story line with her dying who knows i
actually hope though she's in dead
because again she's so fascinating in
the present timeline to be watching with
everybody in the office it's just an
interesting character but we'll see and
even if she did pass away it's setting
up more characters to meet throughout
this huge building that again the
possibilities are endless in the show
and it's just another great episode and
i feel like the show's just getting
better and better i'm giving this one a
9.7 i am so hooked right now i haven't
been to the show so much since westworld
season one it has that good of mystery
that good of sci-fi elements but the
character studying it with everybody is
fascinating but not even just character
study but study about the workplace
right and it's just also hitting it
because it's timely with the current
state of affairs we're in in this
country so i think that's just awesome
and that's everything working in the
show we're seeing it with this show in
my opinion and i can't wait for what's
to come i want to hear all your theories
let me know down below all your thoughts
everything about this and yeah if you
liked it you didn't like it i'd just
love to hear it i really do i'm so
excited with the show so i'll read every
comment again respond as many as i can
please please make sure to subscribe it
helps me in so many ways you have no
idea it will help me do more videos for
you guys in the future and if you really
do here please donate today and become a
member you'll get special perks and
again it'll help me just make more
content for you guys and hopefully do
this full time one day please also
follow me at steve varley show on
twitter instagram and tick tock for more
of me and i'll see you next time